love 90 day fiance i mean obviously love
in paradise
how can you i mean amazing um let's just
start off right after that something
that surprised me about your story was
that neither of you really spoke the
others language like you don't speak a
lot of spanish he doesn't speak english
so how did you guys initially connect
you know it's actually really funny um
when we met he
he tried to write to me in english so he
was using google translate so it was
like i couldn't really get it in the
beginning i was like oh i see what's
happening here because i also i work
with international students so it's
something i'm kind of used to
so i'm very like well-versed in working
with people who don't speak the language
that i'm trying to
work with them in so it's something that
that i have experience with but i think
that
it makes you not fight about all the
things i think that that's what's been
really cool about it is it like you
really have to pick and choose your
battles is it worth you know going
through the translation and finding the
nuances and language so i think that
that kind of made it interesting and
exciting for me because i was like oh i
can't fight about all the things
if we can't communicate so
kind of like that um how do you guys uh
do communicate though is it like an app
that you guys use
we primarily speak spanish
got you okay cool
um i also i have to ask you about the
height difference says you're 411 and
he's six seven correct yeah
so what is the reactions that you sort
of get from people
everybody's staring at us
everybody's serious people yell things
at us um one woman at the beach once was
like obuso
you know it's like like abuse like that
must be abusive yeah it was it was then
he was just like he looks at me like do
i abuse you
[Laughter]
oh my goodness people are very floored
by it and i think that either one of us
attracts a lot of attention and i think
the two of us together attract a
ridiculous amount of attention so it's
you know it's a blessing and a curse i
think sometimes
i got you um you know what was it about
johann that
like initially
drew you to him
i mean first i think it's obvious he's
beautiful you know he's a presence it's
just
there's something about him that has
like this king energy you know that just
he can own a room and i'm a lot i have a
lot of personality i'm loud um i take up
a lot of space and sometimes it's hard
to find people who can match that energy
as soon as i saw him i was like
okay i think that i could work with this
you know because he's just he's so big
and so and even just the way that he
speaks like he is a presence and i
really respect and love that about him
because
it he also has a heart you know so it's
like a really awesome balance of like
you know the strength and this um
i don't know it's almost like a a
protective energy but also very sweet
and very endearing well that's lovely
um
in one of the
scenes that i saw it said that you
hadn't told anyone what you were doing
do you mean you hadn't told anybody that
you were going to dr to get married to
johan or you didn't tell anybody about
johan in general um i didn't tell most
people about johan in general i really
didn't i kind of kept him to myself for
a while i think that
um
i'm generally a pretty private person
which i'm sure is surprising but
i you know i generally keep my personal
life to myself unless i'm really really
sure about what i'm doing or
um
unless there's a need to share with
people and i kind of just felt like let
me do this thing for me
let me do this thing for me let me try
this thing for me and see if it works
and if there's something to share i'll
share it and if there's not something to
share i won't share it and it kind of
leaves it open
um when you did tell people or the few
people that you did tell um what was
sort of their reaction uh to you guys
sort of
um
falling in love so quickly and you know
be living in two different countries and
all of that
i mean i think most people are pretty
supportive because they know that i'm
grounded and they know that if i'm
making a decision it's not one that i'm
making without thinking about it i think
most people also know
um
that you can't really say anything to me
so it doesn't really matter like
everyone's gonna be like
nice danielle good luck good job good
work i hope it works out for you that's
what most people are gonna say most
people aren't going to say i don't think
you should make this decision because
there's never going to be a moment where
i'm like oh okay
never mind then you know like that's not
really my nature so i think
or even if they're not supportive behind
the scenes they're very supportive to my
face
you're like i'm going to do what i'm
going to do in my own person
exactly i got you i get you um
there is an age difference between you
guys um
did you
are there parts of the uh your
relationship that you find difficult
because of that age difference or do you
feel like it's not really a problem
um there have been times where
i think the difference in life
experience you know with we age isn't
really an issue unless there's a life
experience difference and i feel like
you know
a lot of the things you'll see on the
show are the results in the differences
in our life experiences
you know and i think it's not really
about the number it's not about the year
it's more about like what have you done
in your 32 years and what have i done in
my 42 years i think that's where the
differences are
i got you i got you
um
you know
when you do a show like this
[Music]
say
you're
lot of people are gonna have opinions or
things like that what do you want people
to know about you or your relationship
or your story for watching this
i think that
i it's important first of all for people
to know that we're real people
you know we're humans just like everyone
is humans and to give us grace
um
that i think is really important i think
um
whenever your relationship i mean just
imagine having a relationship under
scrutiny in this way and being televised
in this way like there's always going to
be ups and downs there's always going to
be challenges
and i think you know giving people grace
and and refraining from judgment and
trying to learn from the experiences you
see on the screen i feel like that's
what i would love people to take away to
take away like learning something about
relationships that was the reason i
chose to do the show and and
um
you know that that still is you know my
mission as i'm as i'm even promoting it
it's like what does a relationship look
like what are the problems that exist in
relationships and and how do we solve
them
um
in a way that that doesn't damage anyone
were you surprised at how quickly you
guys fell for each other
yes
yes i think i was i was very surprised
in my own behavior um
and just how how willing i was to be
able to just go back to the dominican
republic by myself and and
spend time with this man that i barely
knew i think how fast i was willing to
go and spend time with his family like
you'll see on the show
you know we move pretty quickly and i
think for me it's about my age
you know like
i don't i don't really have time to
waste you know so like i want to try
something and see if it works and if it
doesn't i'll move on like that's kind of
how i am at this stage in my life so
yes i'm surprised that that we fell for
each other as quickly as we did but when
i also think about who i am as a person
that's kind of how i move i'm always
like that's what i want
i just
i love that um
the last thing um like uh just a couple
more questions but um what i know you
probably can't say too much because we
obviously have to say before the show
but what can you sort of tease about
your future together and what we'll see
on the show
i think you'll see um
what can i tease about what you'll see
on the show
i think you're gonna see a lot of really
beautiful moments and i think you're
gonna see a lot of really painful
moments and and you're going to see a
lot of struggle and i think you're going
to see a lot of communication
issues and
ways that communication can solve
problems but so it's a lot of ups and
downs and a lot of challenges
for sure